je ne comprends pas monsieur j'ai résolu
plus à faire que n'importe quel agent
elle est l'agent le plus cool c'est du
fbi à vos collègues ne vous aime pas
écoutez moi je compte 10,4
elle est le flic le plus déjanté de
rostov regardez là je crois que cette
femme a de gros problèmes psychologiques
en vous coopérez c'est leur meilleur
enquêtrice par le réalisateur de mes
meilleurs amis le fbi ayala priorité non
pas là dedans c'est fini maintenant non
plus elle essaie de retrouver mes
couilles
vous n'avez pas vu les couilles du
capitaine par hasard vous me direz elles
sont grandes comme ça vraiment jean xxs
des couilles de petites filles c'est les
flux il y avait des couilles
les interrogatoires ça me colle on entre
et on fait parler à grands coups de
patin juste être un peu patient
en cluster il a des tas de relation avec
des trafiquants de drogue et il est là
ça va pas vous fait tâche je suis un
agent frédéric roy que vous êtes là pour
leur faire leur [ __ ] de comptabilité
c'est quoi ce truc leurs arrêtés c'est
une gaine se sert à tout me tenir en
place pourquoi il ya des trucs qui vont
sortir de vos sous vêtements peut-être
surprise
je sens que j'ai lâché et on leur montre
non c'est pas des conneries il est trop
lourd
aux voix sur un amorti sa chute non
ouais sans lèvres
sandra bullock enlèves à fausser comme
sa part laissé tomber largo ça fait
drôle c'est comme voir une bonne sans
rouler des pelles melissa mccarthy un
bon bien profond pour toi chérie qui
c'était c'était ma mère pas de portable
est maintenant à sa change tout
les flingueuses c'était profit sim 21
août